Speaker 1: All right, let's get into audience
questions, has been a couple of weeks since we
did these and there are many that came in
and many are good. First one, Afghanistan
plus twenty twenty two. David is twenty twenty
two suddenly looking disastrous for Democrats,
given what happened with Afghanistan and the
fact that Joe Biden really needs some kind of
legislative accomplishment. Yes. So there's
one it's sort of still too early to say,
but let's look at the bad and the good. So
the bad is the optics of Afghanistan, which
we've already discussed, aren't good for Joe
Biden. Even though he did the right thing,
we had to leave at some point. You have to say
no more. It was going to be chaos no matter what.
If Trump had done it, it would have been the same
thing. There's no doubt that the Republican Party
has been and they're going to continue just
slamming, slamming, slamming Biden. And then
by extension of that, they're going to be slamming
Democrats for failed foreign policy and wasted 20
years of time in Afghanistan, 20 years we never
should have spent to begin with. But it's clear,
whatever the truth is about Afghanistan, they're
going to use it against Joe Biden for sure.
What is going to happen with the infrastructure
bill? Is it ultimately going to become a full and
total reality news from earlier this week?
Nancy Pelosi working to push it forward.
Joe Biden definitely needs another big
legislate excuse me, legislative win.
And then also there's still the question of
redistricting and gerrymandering, which is not
very friendly to the Democratic Party,
and it's not going to be helpful to them
in twenty, twenty two. So there's a real chance
that the combination of if voters have a long
enough memory and they often don't, for Biden
to be pinned with the disaster of Afghanistan
and for people to care about that enough
to vote for Republicans as a result,
combined with Joe Biden, gets no other big win
between now and the election. I see it unlikely.
And gerrymandering issues, it could be a disaster,
an absolute and total disaster for Democrats.
Now, what about on the other side? What
sort of looks OK, first of all, since April,
Democrats have had a pretty steady three to four
percent lead in a generic ballot over Republicans,
which deals with House and Senate. Now three to
four percent is not necessarily even that much.
I mean, generic ballots in general, it's too early
and it's too narrow for a three to four percentage
point generic ballot lead to tell us very much
about what's likely to happen in, I guess,
what is two, three, 14, 15 months when that
election actually takes place. And then the other
question mark that could be good is a lot of these
Republican governors that are governing terribly,
even though what we're talking about in twenty
twenty two is House and Senate. We're not talking
about Biden and we're not talking about governors,
although some governors will be up for reelection,
the vaccine rollout under Biden. Contrasted to
the disaster of covid escape Florida, the disaster
of covid Housekeep, Texas, Mississippi,
it's ungodly what's happening down there
that is looking more and more likely to still be
a factor as we get into twenty, twenty two. And it
could be something that even though the analysis
will be, did Biden or governors do better,
whichever party is perceived as having done
better, Democrats or Republicans, Democrats
as seen through Biden, Republicans
as seen through these governors,
it may impact the twenty twenty two midterms as
well. It's just too early to know. A lot of this
really will come down to how Republicans run
in twenty, twenty two. And we're going to talk
about that a little bit later. Do Republicans run
on? Biden's been a disaster with Afghanistan and
authoritarian vaccination and all these different
things that are all lies, communism, socialism,
all lies. Or instead, do Republicans choose to
run on something that seems more positive, even
though it could be a disaster sort of getting back
to normal? Let's get let's let's get let's reopen.
Even though everything's basically open, that may
be much more appealing than harping on old talking
points which their voters may no longer care about
by the time it comes to vote. So the answer is,
could 20 to be a disaster for Democrats?
Yeah, it could. It's too early to know